cher citoyen de russie draghi futur
chers anciens combattants je
marque camarades soldats et marins jeune
sergent mutinerie officiers mariniers
aspirants est à l'étude en général
camara des officiers généraux ou amiraux
nyon je vous félicite à l'occasion du
jour de la grande victoire la défense de
la patrie lorsque son destin était en
jeu a toujours été sacré avec ce
sentiment du patriotisme in et les
résistances mobilisés
qui se battait à mon secours à leningrad
et kiev à minsk stalingrad koursk
sébastopol car je kiffe kharkov même une
lacune en vain à chaque vous
combattez pour nom ma chouchoute voyant
pour nogent ce dans le dos de base pour
défendre la russie le 9 mai 1945
marque à tout jamais
le triangle ou de notre peuple uni
mouche de springer le coup de marqueur
cet exploit sans faille d'une période au
front et à l'arrière le jour de la
victoire à eschert tout un chacun en
russie il n'y a pas une seule famille et
en russie l'imi qui
ne l'épargné pas rose mais cette guerre
le régiment des immortels
a maintenant on en veut mes ancêtres
il porte les portrait de nore moss père
grand-père des anciens combattants qui
nous ont laissés nous sommes fiers de
cet esprit a mis la table deux des
vainqueurs il notre devoir est de
préserver la mémoire
de tous ceux qui ont combattu le nazisme
et qui ont tout fait pour que plus
jamais les atrocités de la guerre ne
surgisse et malgré tout les dissonances
la russie a toujours oeuvré pour le
système de sécurité indivisible
nécessaires à la communauté
internationale en décembre
l'année dernière nous avons proposé de
créer ce système mois le la sécurité
nous avons appelé les oxydants se
joindra à nous mais tout est un vin
l'occident n'a pas voulu nous entendre
cela vous dire que il chérissait
d'autres projets et nous l'avons vu
ouvertement il de se préparer à une
opération de représailles dans le dos de
basse et en crimée à kiev en ont parlé
des
possibles est rarement un nucléaire et
le temps se rapprocher de nos
territoires ainsi petit à petit la
menace à une indivisible et pour nous
planer au dessus de nos frontières à
nous montrer que la
l'opposition
des adeptes de banque bear head band des
rats des néo nazis étaient inévitables
je répète nous avons bien vu le
déploiement de l'infrastructure
militaire
nous avons vu des consultations des
fournitures
d'armes et la menace grandissait de jour
en jour la russie a
toutefois opposé à titre préventif
l'agresseur c'était la seule et unique
décision et
juliette à la décision souveraine de du
pays indépendant
les états unis surtout après la chute de
l'union soviétique ont commencé à parler
de leur caractère exceptionnel un
humiliant vis non seulement le monde
entier mais également du tx joni
mitchell a lié cette élite qui fermait
les yeux là dessus et que avaler tout
cela mais nous n'y sommes différents la
russie un caractère différent nous
n'allons jamais renoncer à l'amour de la
patrie renoncer à nos valeurs notre
édition
de nos ancêtres de tous si tu lis à
l'occident gvt à leurs amis line
rtt le bélier ou celle de dégradation
morale
en résulte également que la réécriture
de new star est née la turquie union
victimes
2 c'est la seconde guerre mondiale sont
bafoués
nous savons que les combattants les
anciens combattants qui voulait venir
ici pour qu'on les marie ce jour
n'ont pas eu la permission de se
déplacer mais sachez que nous saluons et
nous rendons hommage absolument à tous
les anciens combattants américains et
d'autres des heures
i stay des partisans un chinois brave
tous ceux qui ont combattu le nazisme
chers camarades
aujourd'hui les milices du donbass avec
le conte prince temps et russes se
battent pour eux
et sur leurs pairs et les soldats
soutien de kent de se voir of the beauty
ville là où les combattants de la
seconde guerre mondiale
que ce bâtiment dans la main au chantier
je me tourne vers vous l'amérique john
bass pourrait au bout du battait pour
votre patrie pour du son à venir pour
que personne n'oublie le lui son viol à
ce boîtier faut qu'il n'y ait pas
exécutée
sur place aujourd'hui nous chérissons la
mémoire éternelle de tous ceux qui sont
tombés
depuis les so what et fils les filles
les
maris femmes
les soeurs les proches
grand-père et les grands-mères nounou
agences donc nouveau devant la mémoire
de tous ceux qui sont tombés qui ont été
brûlées piffard décembre 2014
devant eli civile de du de bath qui sont
tombés sous les tirs des néo nazis nous
nous sommes devant les compagnons
d'armes nos prix sont morts dans un si
bon bah justement tiennent pour la
russie je vous envie d'observer les
minutes de silence
il peut reprendre
rajoy make a wish
chers camarades de gauche devant la
future la morgue de gauche chacun de nos
officiers et niveau sport de soldats de
l'armée rouge les tentes 2 pour notre
super u turn lili et roche a questionné
à l'elysée société civile les
entreprises les régions et l'état vont
tout faire pour aider les familles nous
allons apporter une science tout
particulier les temps celui du lierre
aux enfants de tous ceux qui sont tombés
pour la vie nous avons oublié j'écris
mais aujourd'hui et le décret en ce sens
je ne ferai plus les seuls à l officier
keats onglet siégeront lire celui que le
personnel médical les infirmières et les
infirmiers pour leur dévouement aux
politiques a qu'un seul nom cli jaune
devant l'amour de défendre et de sauver
les vies
amoureuses et périls
chers camarades indices la crasse mais
pour je suis ici sur la villa sainte
justine
est
fier de toi ton âge lecture lisant les
autres intervenants se diriger
maintenant notre n'est pas la verrine
tous ceux qui viennent du front d'une
négation
même du fait que
décennie 2000 est contre nous avons des
terroristes internationaux pour nous
briser pour nous diviser
combattants de toutes les nationalités
sont tous les maux et les blues funda
lisant les noms de façon fraternelle
de l'unité de notre page
bayrou aujourd'hui j'ai pour défendre
les quatre ruches qui a été défendu par
il vous a pas sauf que le chéri chéri
c'est au dessus
l'indépendance et celle là madiot
sécurité deux autres filles
qui
ont vaincu le nazisme archives dans la
guerre grande guerre patriotique buts
nous ont donné une ligne wrangler et
nous allons surtout à mieux vivre sous
l'oreiller exemple gloire à nos martyrs
ou peu bienveillante noir à la russie
doit aller victoire aux reins
[Musique]